tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono qua dj ed oggi siamo sul flop
spero che conoscete tutti questo gioco
se non lo conoscete vi ricordate per
caso qpx i ragazzi oddio ecco diciamo
che da quando ho fatto cupini avete
consigliato veramente tutti di giocare
anche a klopp che è un gioco della
stessa casa di produzione el avete
consigliato perché un gioco di alta
cultura nei quali ragazzi bisogna
comandare un unicorno semi rincoglionito
lago ho provato prima come andava sta
roba ma vi giuro che noi impossibile una
cosa in guardai sicuro p era difficile
sta roba in guarda allora prima di tutto
devo premere questo stavo già sbagliando
tasto ok
bisogna corri brutto stronzo ce la può
fare
ragazzi è fatto a te sì no no no no io
dico ragazzi se commuovi era difficile o
di rho mi sta impennando il cavallo
ragazzi se cupo fine è difficile sta
roba impossibile vi giuro lato ragazzi
vorrei far notare quanto cazzo e sexy
sto coso è morto alla ragazza assetto di
guerra
qualcosa è ok perfetto allora siamo
partiti male potente di aver trovato la
tattica buona credo di aver trovato la
tattica buona ci sono dei sassi ma sono
l'ostacolo abbastanza grande per me ok
come un legno forza ragazzi non sarebbe
poi così difficile se non si muovesse
comunità celebrato mentale un letto e
lei la tattica
la tattica ragazzi ho trovato la tattica
giusta ho trovato la tattica
fottutamente ma che mai dato è
bellissimo come muore perché sembra tipo
una roba tristissima a tante ragazze o
scopo di sta roba quale dovrebbe essere
cioè trovare la principessa quella che
c'è in basso a sinistra
no perché non capisco dove cazzo devo
arrivare mai così no no le scale
l'escala ragazzi è scientificamente
provato che gli unicorni non riescono a
salire le scale che ragazzi già posso
fare non è così difficile su due ruote
su due ruote ragazzi dei pazzi che cazzo
cazzo sei scappato
ma come cazzo fastigio pare sotto
fiorino minuscola l'edizione ragazzino
la7 no no no fermo per ma porca [__]
non è possibile si sta muovendo come non
lo so se c'è una crisi epilettica
che cazzo qua manca [__] ragazzi che
cazzo succede mi sono morte le gambe di
dietro maledizione sono io potrò
beccarmi un cazzo di di corno che li
tiri muoiono le gambe di dietro casa
come cazzo faccio a muovermi sai che da
quel culo per culo amico mio hai così
ceca czech era ragazzi queste qua il
trattamento di unicorni io io io non ho
altre parole per descriverlo perché non
si può mandare un unicorno a correre e
non li funzionano le gambe che il cazzo
fa fermo 6 calma allora devi muovere
anche quelle dietro non ed impegnerà
ragazzi come cazzo si sono picchiate le
gambe dell'unicorno qualche a [__] non
è che qualcuno conosce un buon meccanico
cose del genere avanza porca [__]
avanzata che giova poi fanno no fermo
faro frega direi che ho trovato la
velocità giusta ma vaffan
allora io la prossima io l'ignaro
ufficialmente guerra ai sassolini
maledizione del prossimo il prossimo
sasso che becco irrigiditi un'incornata
di quelle che si ricorda per tutta la
vita maledizione devi muoverti cavallo
se poi non è un cavallo l'unicorno io
chiamo cavallo ok ok sucate sassi su tre
ragazzi ho superati i sassi non so come
cazzo sto facendo ma ci sto facendo
ciao sto facendo per farlo in un
soffitto porca [__] cia stavo facendo
moro o no ragazzi io credo seriamente
che questo gioco debba pacchetto a
passare assolutamente alla storia perché
non ho mai vista una roba così
cioè è un misto tra ok ok lo spettacolo
superato un traguardo per me non ce la
faccio quasi mai ok ok ho chiesto per
battere record superdome fermo fermo
cavallo bravo fido ho chiesto a posto la
ragazza già posso fare non è difficile
ma devi andare avanti devi andare avanti
stupidi unicorno avanti no no no
ragazzi ho io ve lo giuro voglio un
premio nobel adesso subito a chi cazzo
ammezzato soggetto perché non vi giuro è
fantastico e la è la cosa più più bella
più bella e culturale che abbia mai
giocato in vita mia e un sasso e un
sasso che è il bravo sondheim in più
adesso sono più sassi ok ok sono stati
non è di sono stasti madonna non sono
dei suns di merda già poi pare ce l'ha
poi porca [__] ragazzi non c'è
l'unicorno che non riuscì a superare
esami
non è così allora io io a voce dopo lo
spin non so come faccio ti può
prenotarsi a caso come adesso come
adesso come adesso
oh mio dio ragazze ragazzi state
registrate in questo momento per l'amor
di dio nella storia delle entrare ok ok
ok quasi record quasi record nuovi con
le gambine è un gradino è un gradino
mariah faccio l'ultima e ci rinuncio
perché sono ben guardabile non riesco a
comandare un cazzo di unicorno capitemi
ci vuole la patente presta roba come
senza fatta che a portarmi in avanti non
lo so va bè ragazzi del decidete voi se
cielo la patente da ogni giorno ogni mi
piace al video una potente praga
scusatemi se ne provo un altro ma son
troppo curioso di vedere che cazzo si
sono inventati per cos'è sta roba
credevo di battere ma ho fatto un file
della madonna
ok ok
cos'è sto schifo vai grande cos'è palco
ma che cazzo ragazzino non è difficile
ce la posso fare per professionisti
questo madonna madonna sembra che sta
schiacciando formiche una cosa così
ragazzi non ha senso devo devo braccio
ti stai [__] fermi fermi ho fatto
parla ma si può essere più [__]
ma dai ragazzi facciamo così raccontiamo
la vera favola io io vi racconto e poi e
poi voi due vi dite se vi è piaciuta
questa diventando un campo di di tipo di
palle a caso vai
ok sto facendo più punti così che che
mai prima d'ora che aspettate un attimo
no ma [__] ragazzi poi c'è ancora
questo che l'ultima volta vi giuro ho
provato a scazzo ma stavolta sono pronto
un tentativo quello della vittoria lo
dongle armi fino alla b ok ok si madonna
ragazzi sto facendo acrobazie
incredibili non so come cazzo sto
facendo ma va bene così ma [__] al
pc bravo così togliti dai [__]
togliti dai [__] vai così anche a
calci lo piglia calci si grande cos'è
ragazza allora nn de vito acquisto
piccioni di merda togliti devo prendere
no no no non tags armento azzardare un
pazzo stato ogni ti faccio passare le
pene dell'inferno maledizione togliti
dalla j
e la mia lettera non puoi non puoi du
comma che si mette si mette su quelle
che mi sembra vuoi che è stronzo
sì sì ok ragazzi credo di stare per
arrivare al traguardo che sono quasi
convinto e la cosa è fantastica vi giuro
non ci posso credere a prendere v
profumate andata bene che non te l'ha
infilata leica pranzi la mano perché te
lo meritavi tutto maledizione come cazzo
fate o forse adesso devo saltare per
forza non ci arriverò mai euro
saltare lo salta ragazzi no no non ci
credo
ragazzi ero vicinissimo da d'ora in
avanti fare una partita gip
ogni volta che finirò gioco hanno senso
perché dovevo finirlo cioè ormai mi è
entrato qui perché già in testa di
finirlo i ragazzi non ce la faccio devo
assolutamente finirlo anche ragazzi se
vi dove piaciuto il comer solito
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come noi video
trovato nella descrizione senza rischi
iscrivetevi di civiltà volo prossimo
video ragazzi